Hey youtubers it’s charlie, since there’s
no new Agents of SHIELD this week because
of the olympics I wanted to do a fun bonus
video.
The real mystery to talk about right now is
the identity of the clairvoyant.
There have been a lot of really awesome theories
but I wanted to float this one to you just
for fun.
It’s all a giant fake out, the real clairvoyant
is Loki.
I’ve got a few other good theories about
who it is that invoke Winter Soldier, Age
of Ultron and the rest of the movies.
But let’s play with this before we talk
about those things.
Here’s 5 big reasons it’s Loki
Number 5 - Tom Hiddleston really wants to
participate in Agents of SHIELD.
When Joss whedon first announced the show,
Tom Hiddleston said he’d love to play a
role.
But, like all great actors, he too busy for
an extended run on a tv show.
Plus there’s the added fact that he’d
totally steal any scene he was in making things
really confusing for the writers and the audience.
But that doesn’t mean he couldn’t do a
very brief cameo in a kind of classic villain
reveal during the finale.
It would be a really strong way to end the
series and capture more avengers fans for
season 2.
Number 4 - Since the events of Thor The Dark
world Loki has been ruling asgard disguised
as Odin.
Asgargians have great toys, but the all-father
has a special observatory that helps him see
things in the way Heimdall does.
This would give him the appearance of clairvoyance.
But even if he didn’t have special toys,
regular asgardian technology would be enough
for him to peep on everyone if he chose to.
Number 3 - He does have a small axe to grind
with Coulson.
Remember just before he died in avengers,
Coulson really shook his confidence for a
minute and then shot him with the destroyer
gun.
They never did explain how that worked.
Loki probably wouldn’t just be planning
mass chaos just to take a swipe at coulson,
but he is the god of mischief.
So he might just be killing two birds with
one stone.
Number 2 - It’s a way to keep Tom Hiddleston
involved in the franchise even though he’s
not going to be in any movies until phase
3.
Everyone wants a loki movie, but Marvel has
made no plans to make one.
So how do they keep the fandom happy and save
themselves 200 Million Dollars?
By just including him in their tv show.
Side note, Tom Hiddleston is also kind of
Marvel’s international ambassador for public
events.
Something which he loves doing and we all
love watching him do.
and my number 1 reason why it could be Loki
- Asgard has been a huge part of the story
this season.
First you have the rage spear from last year,
now Lady Sif is getting her own episode.
Each time they keep escalating things.
The next step up the superhero ladder would
be someone major from the movies.
And Chris Hemsworth is shooting avengers age
of ultron in england starting this week.
So he’s definitely not going to be on the
show.
Which leaves Loki.
All that being said here are a couple of other
alternatives that make sense given it’s
someone who will tie into Captain America
Winter Soldier and Age of Ultron.
The best real theory is Armin Zola of Hydra
from Captain America.
The character has been the big villain featured
in the captain america comic books last year.
He teased that he’d be coming back in winter
soldier as MODOK.
Marvel’s big comic book stories tend to
precede the films by about a year or two.
So the timing lines up.
The other theory is The Leader.
Samuel Sterns.
In the prequel comics he was being kept in
the same facility the tesseract experiments
were being done.
He’s been a relatively minor character and
Tim Blake Nelson, the actor who played him
in Incredible Hulk would be a lot easier to
get than say Tom Hiddleston.
He’s so smart that it could be construed
as clairvoyance.
The other theory is that it’s the real Mandarin.
But I think this theory is less likely.
If you consider that skye is half chinese,
and I’m expecting her status as a 0-8-4
to tie in with the clairvoyant, I’m thinking
the mandarin is her real father.
That being said the mandarin being revealed
on a tv show and not a big budget movie is
really unlikely, so I think MODOK or The Leader
are better bets.
Crossing my fingers for Loki though.
Wouldn’t it be bad ass if Loki was Skye’s
real father.
As if she came from the SKye.
I feel like the writers are just teasing us
with word play.
I’ll be doing a bonus arrow video tomorrow
and my Game of thrones Q&A, be sure to subscribe
to get everything.
And they just cast a bunch of characters including
the pengiun on fox’s gotham tv show.
I’m waiting till they cast bruce wayne to
do a video for that.
Right now click here to learn all about the
flash tv show with grant gustin and click
here for my last SHIELD video.
Thanks for watching, see you tomorrow.
High Fives!